the daily wire has this report social
media platform Instagram has been
accused of helping to facilitate
connections between a vast pedophile
Network according to a report from The
Wall Street Journal and academic
researchers the journal alongside
researchers at Stanford University the
University of Massachusetts Amherst
reported that Instagram allowed and
promoted accounts that openly buy and
commission underage sex content
quote Instagram connects pedophiles and
guides them to content sellers via
recommendation systems that excel at
linking those who share these interests
the journal and the academic researchers
found
the researchers found that Instagram
enabled people to search explicit
hashtags such as quote pedo
and uh or hashtag pedo and hashtag
praying T preteen sex
so these are hashtags that you did on
Instagram you can search
and Instagram apparently has not
disabled those hashtags which it could
easily do
and that connects them to accounts that
use the terms to advertise child sex
material for sale
accounts will post menus quote unquote
that offer inappropriate content
including imagery of the minor
performing sexual acts with animals
that's in quotes
um other menus reportedly offered videos
of children hurting themselves or
meetups with kids so I mean
it's hard to even read this but
uh to summarize
on ins on Instagram there is this
coordinated uh effort and conspiracy
among a vast network of pedophiles to
prey on kids and to share uh this kind
of material
and Instagram apparently allows it I
mean there's there's
a lot of really basic things they could
do to shut a lot of this down and
apparently they are not doing it
so what do we do about that Father's Day
is coming up and this Father's Day let
your dad unleash his inner Grill Master
whether he prefers a sizzling steak or
savory grilled chicken look no further
than the gift of meat from our friends
at good ranchers good ranchers offers
rib eyes New York strips T-Bones all
natural burgers and all the most
delicious chicken you could ever want
plus right now you get 30 off with our
code Walsh at goodrancers.com good
ranches also offers a price lot
guarantee for the next two years as well
imagine if you could have locked in your
price two years ago you would have saved
hundreds of dollars not sure how to
grill the perfect steak well they have
tons of recipes on their website like
our favorite how to cook a steak better
than Gordon Ramsay uh which is quite a
promise but it does deliver whether your
dad is a steak lover a barbecue
Enthusiast or just enjoys a good
old-fashioned Burger good ranchers has
something for everyone order today and
make this Father's Day a sizzling
success head to goodranchors.com use our
code Walsh for 30 off any box that's
promo code Walsh at goodrancers.com
goodrancers.com American delivered
well I mean on on the legal end for one
thing you start holding these platforms
accountable
like accountable and what I mean by that
is burning them to the ground legally
speaking
if they aren't doing anything to prevent
you know
um child pornography from being
distributed on their platform
to prevent children from being actively
preyed upon on their platforms
this thing where they are totally exempt
from any kind of liability whatsoever
has to end
that's the first thing that needs to be
done
and then the second thing which is
really the first thing on an individual
basis is that we as parents have to uh
make some decisions about whether or not
we're going to allow our kids onto these
platforms and to me as you know because
I'm on this uh you know I'm standing in
the soapbox every single day
it's an easy decision you don't you
don't allow your kids on these platforms
you don't give them the phones with
internet access this is what you're
giving them access to or more more
specifically this is who you are giving
uh who you these this is who you're who
will be able to access your kids so it's
not just about what your kids can access
it's now that it's it's that your kids
are now accessible
for all these perverts and degenerates
out there
it really is allowing your kid on a
social media platform
it is it is very similar to dropping
your 10 year old off at some CD bar
downtown for the day and leaving them
there and you know going to run errands
or something
when you think about all the people who
are there who are who your your child is
now is now totally vulnerable and is in
this in completely inappropriate to say
the least environment for a child
not at all equipped to navigate it to be
able to protect themselves to understand
what the risks are
and that's that's the downside
to putting your kids on these platforms
what the hell is the upside
what is the up we know what the downside
is
you let your kid on the social media
platforms the downside is uh
they become totally obsessed with it
they they you know forfeit their actual
childhood in favor of like the screen
they become addicted to the screen they
don't know how to even be a they don't
know how to socialize anymore they don't
know anything they're constantly their
lives become absorbed by the screen
that's one consequence
the other even greater consequence is
all of the horrific
content and material they're now going
to be exposed to
and all of the degenerate monsters who
can access your kids now those are all
the downsides
along with many other deserts
what is the upside
and I can't think of I can't think of
any upside actually I cannot think of
any upside
to allowing your child on something like
Instagram
and even if you could think of one I
don't think it's going to be one that
outweighs
all the downsides I just listed
and yet even though it's all downside
and these are major I say downside these
are like major major problems
and there's nothing on the other side on
the other end to to counterbalance that
still you've got millions of parents who
say yeah well you know go ahead
it's mind-boggling to me if you'd like
to see what else I have to say you can
access my full show by going to
dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
wall Show Twitter page hope to see you
there Godspeed